there is an argument being made by
opinion writer Keith Naughton in the
hill that Donald Trump may not make it
to the primaries forget about Trump
might not win the Republican primary
Naughton is arguing that Trump may not
even make it to the primaries let's
explore whether this might be possible
one of the things that Naughton asks is
whether Trump could quote flame out and
not even make it to the Iowa caucuses
and not in his article and I will link
to it I encourage you to read it lists a
number of sort of strategic and polling
and legal issues that could affect
Donald Trump to start with Naughton
argues you know Trump's polling is kind
of soft when you think about the fact
that he's a former president
and that he's declared and no one else
has and that that polling support for
Trump is already getting worse since
November 8th Trump isn't even scoring 50
percent against people that aren't
running so the first question is check
the facts is that true and the answer is
it is absolutely true if you look at
recent polling
um in Trump versus DeSantis there's a
newish Harris poll which does have Trump
well ahead of DeSantis but remember that
DeSantis hasn't even announced that he's
running and Trump still can't get to 50
percent in a Republican primary this is
not a national poll here this is the
Republican primary poll former president
only guy who's announced not polling 50
percent that is a concern there is a
yougov poll from a few days prior this
is from last week
that one straight up has Trump losing
Trump is losing to DeSantis who is not
even running at this point in time so in
thinking through Heath Naughton's
argument
so far he's correct Donald Trump is
losing a bunch of polls and even in the
polls that he's winning he's failing to
get 50 percent
in a primary
against people who aren't even running
that is not good for a former president
now the counter to the poll story you
all know the counter to the poll story
which was in 2015 into 2016 during the
last contested Republican primary
people were saying the same thing this
guy can't win he's doesn't have the
polling support it's going to be Jeb or
it's going to be Ted Cruz or it's going
to be somebody else you know Marco Rubio
I don't know whoever Ron Rand Paul
um and everybody who said that was wrong
the difference is now
it's a little bit weirder that Trump has
such soft polling even after announcing
despite the fact that he's all pulling
against people who aren't even running
because he spent four years as president
and he is in a sense the leader of the
Republican party or at least has been
for a period of time so I think that is
a concern the next problem that Keith
Naughton points out in his article is
that Trump has nothing new to offer
now the question is whether that's a
problem it's absolutely true
if you listen to Trump's announcement
speech it was verbatim the same speech
he's been giving for a year or even
longer
whether it's a problem that Trump has
nothing new to say remains to be seen do
people want something new and I believe
the answer there is it depends who
you're talking about
Trump's hard and fast followers who buy
the gear
go to the rallies repost the memes those
types of people I don't think they want
anything new they want the exact same
speech about you know teaching
transgender and we're going to ban men
and all this different stuff but there
is a growing faction of the Republican
party some of them have been interviewed
on Fox News recently who want something
new and different the difficulty for
Trump is he can't win just with his base
That Base lost him 2020. and some of
them are becoming demoralized so you've
got to find some new people and the same
messaging is unlikely to capture it I
think he's absolutely correct there
Naughton also talks about the
unpredictable nature of Trump's legal
troubles and how those may impact what
happens in this campaign I think that
that is true it's a real consideration
we just don't know the full scope of
what will happen which makes it
difficult to say here's how it will
affect Trump's race lastly
how does Naughton get to Trump May quit
before the primaries Naughton's argument
is that for Trump quitting and saying I
don't need this crap it's my choice I'm
going back to be a rich guy or whatever
it's better than Trump losing a primary
and that's why Keith Naughton in his
piece for the hill argues this is not
going to go well for Trump the polling
will be so bad that even Trump will be
worried because remember if the
polling's a little bad Trump will come
up with oh that's push-poling and
they're trying to get people to stay
home I don't believe the polling the
polling may be so bad that Trump will
believe I've got to get out rather than
be humiliated by not even as the former
president losing a primary is very
embarrassing there is one more
interesting point here
can we imagine Trump winning a New
Hampshire primary right now a republican
New Hampshire primary the last poll from
which is one of the early primaries the
last poll from New Hampshire was from
UNH in June June and it had DeSantis up
by two in New Hampshire Trump hadn't
announced and DeSantis hadn't announced
Trump's problems have grown since June
and DeSantis favor has increased among
Republicans since June
if it's so difficult to imagine Trump
winning a New Hampshire Republican
primary
Keith Naughton's argument starts to make
a lot more sense what do you think let
me know in the comments on YouTube and
make sure that you're subscribed
when you're looking for a good
documentary to watch you scroll through
Netflix and Hulu for a while there
aren't that many you realize you've seen
the good ones what if I told you there's
a streaming platform exclusively for
documentaries with the best selection
where you won't run out of top quality
documentaries that is curiosity stream
with a massive catalog of the newest and
best documentaries classic titles from
years ago exclusive content you can't
find anywhere else I just watched
Pompeii disaster Street I visited
Pompeii in Italy before I wish I had
seen the documentary before visiting
because it was made very clear I missed
a lot when I actually went to Pompeii
you can watch curiositystream on all of
your devices they're always adding new
titles politics philosophy True Crime
nature they have everything and my
audience gets curiosity stream for under
two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below